Ben Shapiro joins us now enter in chief
of the Daily wire syndicated columnist
host of the Ben Shapiro podcast Ben
first off do you feel as though the
coverage has been balanced like for
example we just showed you know I mean I
think that there's so many media outlets
that are acting as propaganda arms for
Hamas that it's actually quite
incredible Hamas has not been unclear
about their intent here they've been
saying for weeks they want to send
literally a hundred thousand people to
storm the border with Israel Hamas has
been obvious they say we want to break
in we want to kill Israelis
they're not hiding the ball here and the
media are hiding the ball the media are
playing propaganda wing for a for a
terrorist group which has made clear
their intent there are people who are
storming the border attempting to kill
Israeli soldiers sending kites with
incendiary devices over the border
flinging Molotov cocktails at people who
are Manning the border flinging stones
and people Manning the border and the
Israelis are acting with their usual
restraint and the media are treating
this as those Raley's are in
indiscriminate fashion killing civilians
it's just a lie but the me you've been
doing that for years
then what do you think the people who
were in that sound bite montage right
there would prefer the Israelis do yeah
I mean the answer is that they would
prefer the Israeli stop existing because
these are the two choices it's not that
Kumasi is not in control of the Gaza
Strip you heard one of the people in
that montage say that these are people
without a state Israel withdrew from the
Gaza Strip in 2005 okay the Gaza Strip
has been entirely under the control coma
since 2006 when the Palestinians elected
Hamas in an overwhelming majority Hamas
is a State Department designated
terrorist group and one of the worst
terrorist groups on the planet and yet
we're supposed to believe that this is
Israel's fault the Hamas is trying to
storm the border it's beyond all
definition and the attempt to link it by
the way with the Jerusalem embassy
opening is just insane this has been
going on for weeks it's just the media
haven't wanted to cover it and they'd
prefer to blame President Trump for
Hamas trumped up violence than to
actually lay the blame or lay blame at
the feet of the people who are creating
it what are the leaders of Hamas telling
those people to do so they're telling
them to storm the border they've
actually the Washington Post okay which
is a left-wing outlet reported that the
leaders of Hamas were telling people
that the Israelis had withdrawn from the
border that the Israeli soldiers were no
longer Manning the border and then if
they ran up to the border and attempted
to breach the border everything would be
fine they're lying to their own people
they're using human shields 10 of the
people who have been killed work ammas
operatives open Kumasi operatives so
none of this is a surprise this is what
terrorist groups do in a terrorist group
attacking a border even using human
shields is still a terrorist attempt for
children yes I mean they're using
children as human shields this is what
camasta is during the last Gaza war
Hamas actually hid its its headquarters
inside a hospital because again this is
what terrorist groups do when terrorist
groups get a civilian killed they are
happy because they know that the media
coverage will be that Israelis killed
civilians when a civilian is killed in
the camasta stand and in the Gaza Strip
then the Israelis are deeply devastated
about it this is something Golda Meir
once I said we can forgive them for
killing our children we can never
forgive them for making the for making
us kill theirs